hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast emerging diagnostic
strategies to support C difficile
infection control presented by dr. Lance
Peterson past director of microbiology
and infectious disease research program
past director of Medical Microbiology
fellowship and current epidemiologist
Northshore University Health System and
clinical professor Pritzker School of
Medicine University of Chicago I'm
Alexis Krause elaborate and I'll be our
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by lavage and sponsored by Roche
Diagnostics let's get started before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question and click on the
send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for it at the
end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the side
window if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on that answer
question box located on the far left
your screen this
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I'd like to know J juice our presenter
dr. Lance Peterson thank you very much
for the question and thank you for
joining me this is a topic that is
current interest in changing quite a bit
the laboratory ends up being right in
the middle of all of the diagnostic and
prevention measures and we're going to
talk about that today first these are my
potential conflicts of interests over
the years our group has done studies
with many industry groups as well as the
government and gotten research grants
from them I continue to do some
consultations for the groups mentioned
here on the slide and again a reminder
this presentation is sponsored by Roche
Diagnostics so we will be talking about
some of the new products that they have
that fit into the solutions for this
particular problem
what I'd like to talk about today is a
little bit of the disease overview for
clustering difficile and the role of
diagnostic and testing options and then
understanding some of the C difficile
epidemiology which continues to evolve
and we continue to understand better
we'll talk about some new approaches to
clustering difficile infection
prevention and then how to optimize the
seat official testing workflow and what
timeframes really have led to
improvements in prevention for this kind
of infection
first off what is C difficile for in the
acute care setting and basically its new
onset diarrhea and that's what we want
to really focus on when we're trying to
decide who we need to test so we're
looking for new onset diarrhea after
hospitalization or at the time of
hospitalization where there's really no
other explanation as to why the patient
might have diarrhea the epidemiology is
interesting this particular slide shows
that since 2000 there's been a slow
increase in the rate of Clostridium
difficile in hospitals and you can see
that it started at around 5 cases per
thousand discharges and by 2011 really
had gone up to about 12 and the
projection was that it would continue on
into the future the number 5 is actually
a little bit above where we'd like to be
for even a low level endemic rate which
most experts seem to want to keep under
3 cases per thousand discharges so you
can see that that the progression of C
difficile has gotten us into a very high
rate nationally in the United States
this is the more recent data which
really really demonstrates that the
projection has been accurate you can see
that the total cases per thousand
persons has actually increased since
2012 through 2015 and we're both seeing
somewhat of it on somewhat of the
decrease in Hospital onset cases but
this has been accompanied by an increase
in in community onset cases we'll talk
more about this later but we need to be
aware of this because if people are
acquiring clustering difficile in the
community then we have to be very
careful about what antibiotics are given
after they're hospitalized
happen in the past Staphylococcus aureus
has been that really the number one
Hospital onset infection that that has
been acquired as a result of
hospitalization Clostridium difficile
has now overtaken that and you can see
that really beginning in the late 2000s
28 2008 2009 the M RSA was exceeded by
Clostridium difficile by about 25
percent it's important to understand
that cluster diem difficile rarely
colonizes the intestines of healthy
individuals generally three to five
percent of community dwellers may have C
difficile that you can culture from
their school but it doesn't persist and
it's only a transient colonization for a
few weeks in hospitalized patients the
rates may be as high as twenty percent
or more it is an expensive
healthcare-associated infection and the
excess costs are nearly six billion
dollars a year in the US what has been
typical over the years for clustering of
difficile is a new strain would appear
that would go into the hospital and
persist for a few months and then really
be replaced by another new strain
now clustering with difficile strain the
the BI or nav 102 seven strain has
really persisted in the United States
and in some settings that's been hyper
virulent and also multi drug-resistant
including resistance to the
fluoroquinolones so this is this has
really been a change in the epidemiology
of this organism with this century
one of the questions that's important is
how does cost unity of difficile cause
disease there are two large cluster
niall toxins toxin a and toxin B that
are the main variants factors toxin a is
and enter a toxin that stimulates
release of cytokines it really leads to
fluid collection in the gut that's it's
very immunogenic so some of the early
immunoassays really focused on toxin a
but the problem is there are some
strains that don't produce toxin a and
only produce toxin B that still cause
disease toxin B is a well-known psycho
toxin that increases the permeability of
the gut wall and actually disrupts the
actin cytoskeleton that is what gives
the structure to the colonic cells and
it causes them to collapse leading to
diarrhea cell death in itself sloughing
and so toxin B is the generally
considered the main farallon's factor in
toxin a works with toxin B to make
disease worse
it has a wide range of clinical disease
as you can see on this slide the usual
symptoms are diarrhea and cluster M
difficile infection used to be called
cluster of difficile diarrhea as because
of that's the main the main symptom that
or sign that is is seen when you have
this disease and generally the
definition has been at least three bowel
movements per day for two days or more
the definition is slowly moved to three
stools or more per day for one day
because hospitalizations have become
shorter and shorter over the years often
there's fever nausea abdominal pain or
tenderness and the worst disease then is
colitis or pseudomembranous colitis that
can occur in patients and often causes
disease throughout the entire colon it's
important to keep in mind when you're in
the laboratory and looking for who to
test is that we don't normally look for
asymptomatic colonization of this
organism because about ten patients are
colonized for each one with disease so
if we're actively looking for colonized
people and those are the ones we're
going to try to treat we weigh over
treating over diagnose this disease this
of course makes the the testing and
diagnostics much more challenging
because we really need good partnership
with our clinicians so that they
carefully look at who should be tested
and not just send stools for people that
have diarrhea for other reasons it's not
laxative induce diarrhea so generally
you want patients that have been on a
laxative and have diarrhea to have the
laxative stopped before they have their
testing for C difficile to make sure
that the diarrhea persists in the
absence of laxatives
and this is just a schematic with a
photo of what the pseudomembranous
colitis looks like if you do colonoscopy
on these patients and you can see the
little nodules and that's very typical
of what the gastroenterologist will see
when they stick a tube into the colon
and take a look at the mucosa
the outcomes of c.difficile seem to be
getting worse as well and as you can see
on this slide they are quite quite poor
and the risk of recurrence is between 12
and 64 percent depending on the series
with an average of about 22% of patients
having at least one recurrence
complicated clustering difficile
infection can occur in 15% of the
patients and up to 50% depending on the
population treatment failure has gone up
as well and even past it used to be
about three to five percent and now it's
up to 50% in some series within with an
average or median of 21% and then
mortality is the risk of death is
between 8 and 53% which is also quite a
bit higher than it was before this
century in general and the past
mortality was associated with C
difficile infection about one to three
percent of the time so you can see that
this is a disease that is is apparently
much more virulent than it used to be in
something we really want to try to
prevent in our patients
correct testing for c difficile
infection generally still revolves
around either culture or immunoassay and
then the new way to diagnose this is a
nucleic acid amplification test
represented in the middle and these have
been generally available for the last 10
to 12 years
the up-to-date article which lead author
is cliff McDonald from the CDC is a very
good reference for this the the
citations or references are updated
every month and this is the current
current recommendations in that early
diagnosis is one of the important
aspects of this because we want to have
early detection and use contact
precautions with patients that have
suspected or proven clustered of
difficile infection the recommendations
are to continue contact precautions or
isolation at least until the diarrhea
has ceased and many hospitals will
continue it until the patients are
discharged get up-to-date and suggest
using washing with soap and water as a
better way of removing the clustering of
difficile spores from your hand alcohol
does not kill the spores and we'll see
in a minute
that the new guideline from the
infectious disease Society of America
really ranks either of these as equal
but but hand hygiene is very important
to make sure we don't spread this
organism around the hospital
environmental cleaning a disinfection is
critical and does require a sporicidal
agent and most places will be using some
form of bleach to do that
recommendations are to use disposable
medical equipment some of the new things
that are being tried with the impact not
certain yet are ultraviolet light
decontamination of environmental
surfaces routine chlorhexidine bathing
of patients and then admission
surveillance or detection of carriers
this is the new infectious disease
Society clinical practice guidelines
that have just been published and the
strong recommendations with either high
quality or evidence or moderate quality
evidence are on this slide and you can
go read through them you can see that
most of them deal with infection control
practices or treatment of patients the
one that's pertinent to the laboratory
here is that patients with suspected
clustering of difficile infection should
be isolated at the time the order is
placed unless the test is done in less
than 24 hours so if you're doing a rapid
test and getting the results back in
less than 24 hours you likely can only
isolate the positive patients but if it
takes longer than that for the for the
results to be reported the
recommendation is to isolate the patient
until the results are done this can be
used to help justify rapid testing
because if you're isolating everyone and
only about 15 to 20 percent of your
patients are positive that means you're
isolating 80 to 85 percent of people
that don't need it isolation is
expensive so to save the savings and in
not isolating pick not isolating
patients that don't need to be in
contact precautions can be applied to
more rapid diagnostic testing and that's
how we justified rapid testing in our
facilities
this particular slide looks at the guide
the new guideline recommendations for
clinical practice laboratory testing and
you can see that what recommendations
are weak and the evidence is low-quality
which generally means there's no strong
agreement all of the experts on what to
do and so skills it remains up to the
laboratory to figure out what is best
for their or own organization and
generally what it said is if you have an
agreement on who should be tested then
you can use the toxin test as part of a
multiple step algorithm or you can use a
nucleic acid amplification test as as
part of the algorithm if there is pre
agreed criteria then and nucleic acid
amplification test alone can be useful
because it's a very strong way of
telling who really doesn't have
clustering difficile infection
this is a interesting article that was
published two years ago agency for
Healthcare Research and quality or Ark
is responsible for the government
assessment of outcomes in the United
States and this is a clinical
effectiveness review that they sponsored
and if you read through it you can see
that the nucleic acid amplification
tests have the highest evidence with
their outcome for testing with very high
sensitivity and high specificity and the
comment in this particular paper that a
negative algorithmic test is the least
effective strategy to decrease the
probability that a patient has clinical
clustering or difficile infection which
that means is that the nucleic acid
amplification tests are the best way to
tell if somebody really doesn't have
infection there's an argument that some
are making that the tests are too
sensitive and picks up carriers and this
is a this is really a confounding issue
for the laboratory and has made it
difficult to come to consensus on on
what to do but clearly it's the most
sensitive rapid test for ruling out this
particular hospital infection
this is an article that was published
again it's a critical review published
in 2017 and they reviewed 11 commercial
assays where there was published data on
their performance and these were all
nucleic acid amplification test and
rocha assay was not part of this review
because it had not had the data
published as yet but there were only
three of the available commercial tests
with consistent sensitivity and
specificity above 90% at the time that
was the Cepheid expert test the portrait
toxigenic c difficile test and the
Illumina gene c difficile test the other
nucleic acid amplification tests had
sensitivity or specificity or both less
than 90%
this is the performance of the kovash
4,800 test for cluster idiom difficile
infection and you can see this is
published after that last article that
the sensitivity is over ninety percent
specificity is almost 99 percent
negative predictive value almost 99
percent and the positive predictive
value is 95 percent so again this fits
in with the other nap tests that are
over 90 percent sensitive and over 90
percent of specific and so would be
considered as part of those tests that
have performed the best
and this is the Lea this is this is data
from Europe that has recently been
published and looks again very similar
to the Kobus 4800 you can see the
sensitivity for both is over 90%
specificity
over 90% and the overall percent
agreements 95 percent negative
predictive value 99 percent so this
particular test is proved by the are
cleared by the US FDA but is not quite
available for use in the United States
yet but it but we should anticipate that
it has very similar data or very similar
performance to the Kobus 4,800
and this is what the Kobus 4,800 looks
like it's a automated testing platform
with basically sample in and resolved
out a primary secondary to bloating it's
less than 30 minutes set up for 494
samples and we have used it in our
research laboratory and in our clinical
laboratory processing is very simple
and this is the this is more about the
particular test on the kvass broad range
of both the TOC similar types and rival
types which are just various
terminologies that are used for the
various genetic types of Clostridium
difficile and it's it's has very broad
coverage including the hyper virulent
strain the VI and nap one or o2 seven or
whatever is being used for the
terminology
this is the layout system the layout is
a very small instrument about the size
of a blender and it does one specimen at
a time and the results are available in
20 minutes so basically this the swab
goes into the machine 20 minutes later
you have a result right now it's
available for influenza A B and
influenza with RSV and then strep group
a as I said it's been approved are
cleared by the Food and Drug
Administration the United States and but
not not quite available for use as yet
the quest room difficile infection
epidemiology I think this is where
there's been considerable interest and
we've learned a lot very recently this
is a hospital that was have new
construction in the Chicagoland area in
a minute I'm going to show you a video
but but basically what was looked at was
different buildings and the clustering
of difficile infection all occurred in
the adult units and in the video you'll
see covers about a year and a half and
green dots are patient room blue dots
are patient rooms where there are c
difficile patients over this year and a
half and grey dots or miscellaneous
rooms when you're looking at it I want
you to see if you can envision any
pattern of where the C difficile
patients are showing up and we'll look
at the video now
you
well I've looked at this video many
times and I can't see a pattern and no
one else has been able to see a pattern
so if you couldn't see a pattern that's
the right answer and what this means is
that c.difficile really requires a
comprehensive plan for your healthcare
setting it's not the same as an organism
that the same organism is spread from
patient to patient or from a point
source if you will where there's a
contaminated sink or a contaminated part
of the hospital but generally it's a
disease that can pop up when patients
almost anywhere so we need to consider
that as we're planning our strategy for
lowering this infection this is another
article that looks at the same thing and
what they're looking at is patients with
CDI that have toxigenic strains that
were positive in their stool but the
direct toxin test was negative and how
these related to transmission and what
they found was that about three times
more patients were likely to transmit
the disease if they had both toxin
toxigenic strains in their stool as well
as their stool with direct toxin
positive rather than if their stools
direct talks are negative but but the
direct toxin negative patients were
actually significant contributors to
transmission in the hospital as you
recall from the earlier slide there's
about ten times as many toxin negative
direct stool negative patients that are
asymptomatic that are in the hospital
than those are those with disease so
both groups are thought to be important
infection control targets at this point
both asymptomatic as well as the
symptomatic patients and this is a this
is another slide looking at a little
different aspect of this but coming up
with very similar conclusion that a few
cases of the CDI infection are acquired
from other patients but most appear to
be activation of carriers that were
admission or new transmissions from
asymptomatic patients which means that
we need to look at new approaches
including screening and universal
gloving rather than then typical
infection control tracking use of more
sporicidal cleaning methods to clean up
our environment and then particularly
avoiding drugs the clinicians need to
avoid drugs like extended spectrum
cephalosporins quinolones and
clindamycin in patients that have
clustering difficile colonization so
that they don't progress onto infection
and this is a another study looking at
the same thing looking at the dynamics
of how patients get colonized by the
hospital and vice-versa again this is a
new hospital in sirs at the University
of Chicago after they opened their new
hospital and they looked at what
happened to patient flora and room flora
and when patients first went into the
room they actually acquired what was on
the surface of this of the of the room
so they acquired the room floor first
and that would later in that first 24
hours they started contaminating the
environment which i think is important
from the standpoint that we have to pay
attention to patients when they are
colonized with an organism like this but
we have a little bit of time to figure
it out before they heavily contaminate
their environment
and this is again looking at our data
we're looking at the kind of PCR or the
kind of clustering difficile that
patients are colonized with and if you
look down at the bottom nine of the 12
patients that we that had cluster your
business feel infection after coming
into the hospital had pathogenic Ryba
type so there are certain strains of C
difficile that are more likely to cause
infection than our others and it is
going to be important I think as we move
forward to do a better job of genetic
analysis when we ascribe risk of disease
from transfrom transmissions and this
currently challenging because this
requires a lot of work
so what about admission surveillance for
clustering of difficile infection
prevention this has been talked about
really for a few years but not much has
been done until recently in in 2001
Perry rectal swabs were amplified with a
laboratory developed tests and actually
were found to have good sensitivity and
specificity for detecting the strains in
stool then the glutamate dehydrogenase
enzyme fluorescent antibody test was
looked at and compared to the nucleic
acid antibody test or nucleic acid
amplification test for detecting a
symptomatic colonization and as expected
the NAT test was better in sensitivity
than the gdh test and then finally a
Canadian study looked at what happened
if they did admission surveillance and
this was done in the emergency
department and so they knew what
patients had Clostridium difficile
colonization you can see they had a 57
percent reduction in their cases which
was statistically significant and this
is really the first study to show that
that admission surveillance might be
useful and I was able to clinically
impact the patients that we're having
disease and there's probably two reasons
for this one is that you know who is
colonized to try to prevent transmission
but you also knows colonized so you can
be more careful on what antibiotics
they're prescribed
so we were looking at weather - this
might be helpful for us and we have
looked at the impact of rapid clustering
of difficile infection diagnosis room
cleaning and hygiene UV disinfection and
finally real-time PCR admissions
screening over the last several years
and the screening seems to have had the
most impact we did a pilot at two of our
hospitals one of the hospitals used the
expert test that we did not have enough
compliance with the testing so it
couldn't analyze it but the other
hospital used the kawatche 4,800 tests
and found a significant reduction in
clinical infections from clustering
difficile infection we found that
significant risk factors for
colonization including recent
hospitalization systemic antibiotics
past the difficile in long term care
within six months and so we actually
have started targeting c difficile
screening in all of our hospitals that
began august 1st of last year
we look at the performance of the test
the the cobots test in our hands this is
an off-label use of the assay so you
have to do a validation of it and this
has just recently been published in
Journal of clinical microbiology we
tested eight hundred and eighteen
hundred and three samples and you can
see that the estimated sensitivity was
between 95 and 100 percent specificity
98% with very good positive and negative
predictive values so this basically is a
test where the patients get an intra
anal swab and that swab then is tested
directly on the Kobus 4800 and this is
our results to date as I said we tried
multiple other interventions and the
compliance of each of these
interventions really didn't correlate
with whether we were we had higher or
lower numbers of clustering difficile
infection rates and nothing really
correlated so we started doing the
admission testing and in the year before
we started this the overall case rate
was 6 cases per 10,000 patient days
looked at the first six months data and
in three to four hospitals we've seen a
33% reduction in the clustering of
difficile infection rate from six point
four four to four point two nine cases
per thousand 10,000 patient days and
this is statistically significant the
one hospital was known proven had a
testing compliance under 60 and they've
been working on this and it's now up
near 80 percent so we'll see if that
helps in improvement going forward they
also had a very low baseline rate of 4.6
cases for 10,000 patient days and this
then has made it more challenging to
show a difference but we'll we will
continue to follow this and see if the
rate goes down or we'll talk about this
a little bit more but our goal is to get
the rate down below three cases per
10,000 patient days at all four
hospitals
and this is just a graph of what's going
on all four hospitals are graphed in
this in the more thin lines and then the
overall mean of diseases in the thicker
line and it's hospital it's hospital 3
that is the one that hasn't had a
reduction but you can see it started out
in a very low rate to begin with
so how can we optimize the workflow for
managing of Clostridium difficile
infection I think it's important to
understand the biology a bit of this
particular organism and from an
infection control standpoint organisms
really spread and cause problems either
by evolving in a panic way or a clonal
way and what I mean by that
clonal evolution is where the organisms
don't change a whole lot but they're
very good at spreading yeah these are
organisms like staph aureus and
Mycobacterium tuberculosis Clostridium
difficile is in that same group so that
tends to be on the left end on the right
end these are organisms with a
relatively malleable genetic background
and so they can continue to mutate under
pressure of antibiotics and you'll see
resistance continue to evolve and change
and that so the stewardship becomes
really the main answer how you're using
antibiotics for controlling these
panicked ik evolving organisms but
clonal evolution worse spread is
important is really the infection
control isolation practices that helps
control their spread
how does one become infected well mr sa
is a good model for this and this is
data from our mr sa program looking at
nearly 200,000 patients and if you look
at patients that have either
colonisation by PCR and culture or just
a positive nasal test by PCR but no
positive culture in their nose versus no
mr sa and their nose at all being
colonized with mr sa really increases
your risk of infection more than tenfold
and this is really the same thing that
we've seen with clustering difficile the
first step to getting this infection is
to become colonized so what you want to
try to do is to prevent spread of
colonization of these organisms to new
patients
you can do that you can really reduce
the rates and this is just a slide of
our Mrs a control program where we've
done admission screening and then
isolation of positive patients and you
can see the rates of poor disease went
down very quickly after was started
within a year we had a 70% reduction in
disease and we're down below now three
cases per 10,000 patient days we're
getting close to that with our
clustering of just the sill infection
control program and I this is the goal
we set for us because we do think that
these two organisms behavior is similar
biologically in how they spread in the
hospital and cause disease
but if you're going to do if you're
going to do rapid testing how rapid does
it have to be and this looks at again
staph aureus or mr sa either by culture
and the top is a traditional culture or
chrome agriculture the middle the middle
curve is using breath enrichment and
then the bottom curve is real-time PCR
and we're looking at that that really
the sensitivity of the test and then the
time to detection what we found for mr
si is the that control is based on how
much of the time these patients are in
the hospital they're actually in
isolation and so on the vertical axis
we're looking at the percentage of
isolation days that are missed and what
if we look at the lower curve we
discussed early on how quickly we needed
to do our PCR testing we do batch
testing for Mrs a and that average
turnaround time from receipts from
ordering of the tests to receipt of the
result is 15 hours and we ask the
question then what would happen if we
did the testing on every shift and got
that the time down to about 6 hours so
you can see we only went from missing
15% of isolation days to 10% of
isolation days we didn't think that was
really significant it hasn't been so 15
hours has been fine for Mrs a it doesn't
the curve doesn't go to zero because the
sensitivity is not perfect but if you
make these curves perfect you can see
that even going to six hours you still
only get down to five percent of
isolation days mix mist and that didn't
really think from a practical standpoint
was important from the standpoint of
improving our control and it wasn't
really optimal testing for for direct
culture and reporting you'd miss about
40 percent of isolation days and using
broth enrichment you'll miss about
more than 40 almost 45 percent of
isolation days so if you're using an
insensitive test what this says is that
it's very difficult to get the control
you need because you can't get people in
isolation quick enough
so what are what are the options for
molecular testing of clustering
difficile infection patients and I think
if Hospital practices isolated isolate
upon order then daily testing is really
sufficient to control your clinical
infection if the practices isolate after
a positive test result and you probably
need rapid testing of samples so that
the result is back to the patient in
less than 24 hours as you crawl from the
earlier earlier slide we looked at first
the room contaminates the patient but by
24 hours the patient starts to
contaminate their environment so we we
need to know who is harboring this
organism in order to really reduce the
environmental contamination there's
really no evidence for superiority of
either practice but isolated by an order
if you can avoid 80 to 85 percent of
your isolation the isolate on order ends
up being more costly from a standpoint
of isolation practices isolation
equipment in isolation after a positive
test if it's a rapid and klieg acid
amplification test the testing may be
more expensive but the actual overall
program is cheaper because you don't
isolate nearly so many patients
testing to first surveillance testing to
detect colonization is still a challenge
and we are proceeding forward with ours
because we have had meaningful results
in the first six months it does look
like I mean time from collection to
reporting of under 16 hours is useful
it's sufficient for mrs a control and
like lea pickable to the clustering of
difficile infection we test once a day
six days a week so we're doing Monday
through Friday and Sundays excuse me and
that seems to have be having an impact
and there's a wide range of test
platforms that are available now for
Clostridium difficile as the laboratory
can choose that really fits best with
their workflow and their cost
so in summary
difficile infection really is the new
challenge for US healthcare nucleic acid
amplification testing offers the best
sensitivity to detect oxygen XT
difficile and a negative test really is
the best indication that there's no
disease present from this organism but
not all assays are equivalent so one you
do need to look at the test performance
as to especially sensitivity and
specificity the role of active
surveillance testing at the time of
admission is evolving and as more people
look at this we'll have a clearer
picture of - whether this is useful or
not useful and the opportunity to
optimize the workflow based on
turnaround time requirements and volumes
of testing really exists with current
platforms and there is a wide range of
testing opportunities that the
laboratory can use
this point I want to thank you and we'll
open it up for questions and hopefully
some answers thank you very much
Thank You dr. Peterson for your
informative presentation we will now
start the last webinar you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that answer a question
box located on the far left of your
screen well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is can you
describe your overall c difficile
infection control program
so for us at Northshore we do wrap it
on-site testing we have four hospitals
and we're using the expert test for
clinical diagnosis where the test is
done in seven days a week 24 hours a day
and because of that we don't isolate on
order but we only isolate where the
patients have a confusing a positive
test we also for several years of it as
I mentioned during the talk have been
doing different practices including
using UV light decontamination
monitoring of how well the rooms are
being cleaned by our environmental
services bleaching the rooms after the
patients are discharged the ones that
have had close to native difficile
infection and we really have not been
able to associate any of the these
practices with their reduction in
disease so if a practice compliance is
high it doesn't necessarily correlate
with a low C difficile infection rate
for that given month so our our
sustainable trend in downward infection
is started since we did the admission
screening which which probably makes
sense because we do know most of the
patients were capturing about 80 percent
of the patients that are colonized with
cluster DIMM difficile when they come in
the hospital this way and so we are able
to restrict the environmental
contamination and spread of this disease
we do the the admission screening
testing at the central hospital or
Evanston Hospital and that's run once a
day six days a week Monday through
Friday and then again on Sunday using
the Kobus 4800 and we found that this is
what was used in the pilot that we had a
successful program at one of the
hospitals and we've continued that so it
does appear that the the control of c
difficile from environmental
contamination standpoint and spread to
other patients standpoint is very
similar to that of Mr say that you can
do it on a batch basis once a day and in
that would get the patients that are
colonized into isolation as soon as
possible
the CDI infection control program sounds
expensive how do you justify that cost
it is it's relatively expensive but
we've estimated if we are able to reduce
the Clostridium difficile infection rate
by about 50 to 60 percent we'll break
even higher than that will actually be
ahead in reduced cost for taking care of
questioning difficile infection patients
they're relatively expensive and add
between eight and ten thousand dollars
per patient to healthcare cost just in
the hospital alone so similar to them
RSA if you can reduce these preventable
infections you actually are able to save
expenditures for the hospital the other
thing with both Mrs a Clostridium
difficile they're called hacks which are
hospital acquired conditions and
Medicare finds hospitals for these and
the fines can run over a million dollars
a year so yeah if you if your hospital
is exceeding the threshold that's given
to them by Medicare Medicaid Services or
CMS you'll not only have the added
expense of taking care of the patients
that developed infection but of the
fines from the Medicare program so
there's there's quite a potential to
actually come out ahead and save money
by efficient and effective control of
cause your difficile infection
dr. Peterson what is the rationale for
repeat testing in seven days is the
repeat testing in known positive
patients or those previously negative so
with the how this seven day period came
up was that in the past this beacon
enzyme immunoassays raised it was known
their sensitivity wasn't good physicians
are often to repeat testing until they
had a positive result and I've given
lectures to gastric gastroenterologist
and gastrointestinal surgeons and ask
them when how often they test for C
difficile or this is in the past they
say well they tested and tell they got
the right answer and all of these all of
these tests have a small false positive
rate but after that after really the
first test you've eliminated most of the
true positives and you with with an
enzyme immunoassay where your
sensitivities around 50 or 60 percent
for toxin detection you're you're you
have more false positives with a second
test than you do with the first test so
the rationale is now to do a good test
right at the beginning and then not test
again for at least a week even if
there's persistent diarrhea and you've
had a negative test with with the
rationale for that being that the second
test is more likely to be a false
positive than a true positive clustered
and difficile is not a normal flora in
humans so your transiently colonized
with it but the traction colonization
will last a few months one or two months
if you don't receive treatment so
there's no reason to test if you have a
sensitive test to test more often than
once a week during the same episode of
diarrhea yeah we do not recommend
retesting unless there's a new episode
of diarrhea after the first episode has
resolved so that the rationale is just
been to avoid all these false positives
by stopping doing repeat testing and in
fact
we used to do repeat testing using my
enzyme immunoassays and our overall rate
actually went down when we went to
testing using the Clank acid
amplification test but we only do it
once per week as a maximum because we
avoided all the false positives
our next question is so you are saying
AMA a t-test alone is sufficient to
accurate accurately detect CBI of course
in congruence with signs and symptoms I
did not see diarrhea as a symptom for
admission testing
well most of the people will that that
come in with new onset diarrhea will
have had antibiotics as an outpatient so
you don't have to have the the
antibiotic prescribed in the hospital
could have kind of been obtained from
your your community physician and you
develop C difficile infection at that
point so regardless of whether your your
new onset diarrhea occurs in the
hospital or in the community the
criteria are still the same the only
difference is that you have to be in the
hospital for more than two days in order
to have it be considered a hospital
onset infection which is what the hacks
or the hospital-acquired conditions are
that get that are fine by by Medicare so
the criteria are the same whether it's
an inpatient or an outpatient and
actually about half of our testing or
maybe even a little bit more than half
of our testing is currently on
outpatients
what was the intervention for patients
testing positive with the screening test
so if someone is tested positive with
the screening test they go into contact
precautions and they're treated the same
way as if they have clinical infection
or classroom to facility infection
that's clinically giving them diarrhea
and they stay in that in that contact
precautions throughout their
hospitalization and they're retested
when they come back if they're
readmitted if their test is negative
then they would come out of contact
precautions but if it's positive then
they would remain to our our cluster of
difficile infection screening program
and the Mrs a screening program are
basically both the same as you've had a
history of a positive test either from a
clinical infection or a screening test
you are tested each time you're admitted
and that that admission test drives
whether you're isolated or not for that
given admission
what would you summarize are the primary
advantages to using PCR exclusively over
an algorithm testing approach for C
difficile
well I think over the years I and I did
my training as both infectious disease
and Medical Microbiology so I in the
past have seen a lot of patients with
car stereo difficile infection that
unfortunately the laboratory can only
tell the clinician whether or not the
patient is is has a toxigenic cluster um
difficile in their stool they can't
really make the diagnosis of clustering
difficile infection because there's no
there's no test in the laboratory to
separate colonization from infection so
we've taken the position that we want to
have the most sensitive test available
for knowing whether or not the patient
actually has cluster difficile that's a
toxigenic strain in their stool and then
the clinician has to make the decision
is whether there's an infection or not
unfortunately this requires a lot of
ongoing education of physicians the
taking care patients is there is quite
complex they're pretty sick when they
come in the hospital and so there is
this tendency for a positive test to be
treated and we we spend a lot of time
from infection control discussing with
physicians when they order a clustering
difficile test in the hospital do they
meet the criteria are there no other
reasons for diarrhea like like laxatives
are you have the patients had at least
three loose stools today is there
anything else to the other abdominal
pain have they had fever is do they have
an underlying inflammatory bowel disease
or ulcerative colitis that gives them
diarrhea and we try to on a one one at a
time basis as when necessary educate the
physicians they have been think through
the process of who should actually have
a diagnostic test run for c difficile
our colonization rate is between nine
and ten percent and our infection rate
is right now running about four patients
for
of admission so you can see there our
colonization rate is about 10 or 20
times what the actual infection rate is
and so if you're not very discriminatory
on who you're testing then you're going
to have a lot of positive tests and
patients that don't have C difficile for
us at that since we're very aggressive
on trying to make sure that this
organism doesn't spread in the hospital
we want to also want a test that has a
very high negative predictive value and
as that hrq quality review paper showed
that the best tests for the for knowing
that a patient doesn't have
questionnaire difficile infection is the
natural clay gas an amplification test
dr. Peterson our next question can you
comment on those experts who conclude
that n AAT only testing leads to
overdiagnosis and overtreatment
this is I mentioned briefly during the
lecture that this is an area where the
recommendation of what to do was was was
a low recommendation based on a weak
data and unfortunately you really need
to do what is the consensus is best for
your hospital again my own feeling is
that the laboratory that the roles in
laboratory in this is to tell the
physician whether or not there is a
toxigenic Clostridium difficile in the
stool and then it's up to the clinician
to use their education and their
training to actually decide whether this
organism is or is not causing disease I
there's there's never been a study
that's shown that a less sensitive test
is better at since it's separating
disease from colonization even the
British study that mark Wilcox was was a
leader on where they showed that there
was there was some some excess
diagnostic of Clostridium difficile
infection when used in that test there's
actually no statistical difference
between any of the outcomes between
using an AB test or an algorithm the
only difference was between the
algorithm and people with no testing
done at all so I think that the argument
still is is basically going to be up to
each individual Hospital to decide
whether or not the NAP testing is best
for them in my own personal opinion like
I said I think the laboratory our role
is to tell the patient patients doctor
whether or not there's cluster deem
difficile
that's toxin producing in the stool and
the best test for that is either culture
which can take about a week or ten days
to complete because you have to look for
toxin or the nucleic acid amplification
tests which some of
new assays can give you a result in 20
minutes
dr. Peterson this is a three-part
question how do you classify patients
who are positive by swab on admission
but do not have signs or symptoms of
disease do you treat them for C
difficile how do you then define cases
of true C difficile infection to
accurately determine cases of either
Hospital required versus previously
existing C difficile infection for
reporting purposes
so so for the first one we don't we put
them if they're just screen positive and
have no symptoms they go into contact
precautions they're not treated we did a
study oh probably 30 or more years ago
and Stuart Johnson was the lead author
on that where we looked at what happened
if you tried to decolonize asymptomatic
patients and it basically prolonged
their colonization for about two months
to six months so we don't recommend
trying to decolonize patients with
either oral metronidazole or oral
vancomycin because it just prolongs
their there's colonization and it takes
longer for this tool to become negative
for the patients that are are positive
with symptoms if the symptom onset is
greater than two days after admission
then the criteria of NHSN they're
actually disease that develops in the
hospital so we follow the NHSN criteria
for the diagnosis and reporting of C
difficile NHSN does not count screening
tests as part of the reporting function
so you don't have to worry if you do
screening that that you'll have to be
reporting those results to NHSN it's
only the diagnostic testing so we have a
separate test code for screening and we
do for diagnostic gnosis of clinical
infection
Oh
our next question is what testing
methodology incorporates perirectal
swabs for CDI testing
well right now the paragraph color which
means inter anal so you because the
rectum is actually inside the anus so
you do want to get the swab basically
the little white part at the end inside
of the anus none of the tests are
approved that the test that was used in
Canada in the study where they're short
of benefit was the expert but there was
no analytical validation of that in that
particular paper are the reason we
published our paper that I mentioned in
this in this report was again there's no
FDA cleared test for the Kobus 4,800 but
we wanted to validate it because we
wanted to do the screening test so we
validated the assay in our own
laboratory factually correspondent with
the Food and Drug Administration on this
and they were fine with that they said
once the test is cleared physicians have
a broad broad range of what they're
allowed to do with the test and as long
as we've validated the assay in our
laboratory that they would not take any
action to stop our laboratory from using
acid
and dr. Peterson it looks like we have
time for one more question do you
consider it economically justifiable
using zinc vancomycin Orthodox medicine
in the initial management of toxin
negative but severely symptomatic dgh
positive patients
of the gdh glutamate dehydrogenase so so
about 20% of the c.difficile strains
will will be positive by the gdh assay
and that's because it's part of their
cell structure and they don't produce
toxin so we would not recommend using
either fidex in Iceland or vancomycin in
a patient that was toxin negative now it
depends how you're doing the toxin test
I think that the enzyme immunoassays for
toxins are our cells to have a
sensitivity in the 60 to 70 percent
range so you could miss them but if
you're doing a gdh screening and then
you have a negative PCR test I think
that's pretty good evidence that you
have a nontoxigenic strain it would be
unusual to have both toxigenic and
nontoxigenic strain as president in the
stool I suppose it could happen but it
would be very unusual so I if I had a if
I was doing screening where the gdh test
had a positive test and then had done a
PCR test and it was negative I would not
I'd look for another reason for the
diarrhea and our gastroenterologist SAR
pretty helpful in that they've agreed to
actually do colonoscopy on patients
where there's a question it doesn't come
up very often but I think what you'd
really want to do is rather than is
rather than treating for a disease that
you probably don't think is really there
you'd get some help from the specialist
and the gastroenterologist either
examine the patient or do a colonoscopy
thank you again dr. Peterson do you have
any final comments for our audience I
appreciate the opportunity to talk about
this this is a interesting disease that
I've been working on since early in my
career for probably 40 years and it
still continues to emerge it is really a
challenge as you saw early on in the
presentation this disease is not getting
better
Illinois requires reporting of this
particular infection and I think that
data that's available online if you
google the Illinois report cards you can
look at the data through 2016 and you
can see that in Illinois that the rates
are continuing to rise mrsn rates are
slowly either levelling offered or going
down in Illinois but c.difficile
continues to go up so I think that this
is going to be a disease that will
evolve the laboratory for years to come
and it's important for the laboratory to
be involved in the control efforts along
with infection control
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting question
just a reminder any questions we did not
have time for today by the speaker via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration we would like
to thank laberd's and our sponsor Roche
Diagnostics for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through September of
2018 laborat will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye